need motivation watch a segment believe
nation
hey it's Evan Carmichael and this
channel was designed to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself so get ready for some
convention challenging wisdom from Jack
Ma to give you the confidence motivation
and belief that you need okay let's get
off with rule number one get used to
being challenged people like us we are
getting used to be criticized we're
getting used to be said no people say no
to you when people say yes to you we're
really appreciate because it's not you
know why people should say yes to you
you have to prove so as the ancient
premier you have to get used to be
challenged have to get used to be said
no by the other people by the fact by
the investors by your customers by the
people but this this is the opportunity
when everybody believe it you have no
chance we're only a few people believe
it you believe it you prove it that's
your chance
rule number two adapt to change today
OPM watch has any engineer the cheap way
what cigarette she cuts it song she won
cotton piano
oppa take a shower on what to answer Yan
Tony she doesn't know what young yummy
trans of God
Warren we put you on so just a good
treat at the transom
Tara was she a sofa was the jakkuman so
the sofa off was it suits how you
thought your suggestion at hand that can
say we're here just watch what well
that's this year the show haha yeah you
know it's in queasy about you Michelle
buteau period with you haha
and there's a to termination D'Amato cry
yeah in system 1 efficient she's saying
to her piano others today needs your she
knew you Shapiro ha poor who you thought
about and it would be a while it is
maybe when you pay on holiday senior
higher cheek way rule number three never
give up as a young boy I never thought
you know it is a young boy if ever today
I never thought I would be here honestly
I never thought but as a young boy I
probably when I look back every problems
I met invite when I was a kid benefited
me
I filled so many times people probably
know that I've applied jobs for so many
jobs over 30 jobs all rejected not even
got a chance 24 of us to interview for a
KFC job 23 accepted I was the only got
rejected 5 6 people went full a looking
for a police job
5 except I was the only one my cousin I
applied job as a as a as a server in a
full style to my city we wait a long
queue for 2 hours he was accepted I
reacted so my mother looked at me huh
you know yes but I know this is a
training cost for me
before my thirty years old I'm a failure
well people lose by never give up I
think there is opportunity there and
then I I was a teacher later I bred from
university I was teaching in the
university for six years number five
because number five year I was elected
the best teacher of my universe elected
by students
so I said everything I taught my
students are the things I learned from
books what if I go out to spend a ten
years experience all the things whether
fail or succeed I'd go back to teach
again that was my original thing in
doing Alibaba so I never thought I could
be rich I never thought it would be
successful I never thought we could
survive for eighteen years and then we
made it
rule number four try hard I think
everybody can be successful if you
really try try a hard I study I leave
about 1999 in my apartment I talked to
the 18th founders that one thing we want
one of the things who want to prove if
Jack - team can be successful 80% of the
people in the world they can be
successful because we don't have money
would have technology we don't have
almost nothing the only thing is that we
believe in the future and instead to do
little by little if you want to have
more confidence in self-love check out
my 254 series the links are in the
description below and they are free it's
so difficult to be a small business
in China it took me five months to
$4,500 the people who did the bottom
should believe in the model and I
believe what I do
rule number five don't plan think of
what's in leadership or business plan
okay Julie it's Hamilton make a loan to
the soul raymond laté yes or Tom Vallely
woman chuckles Sergio two can walk away
question of the on ahjusshi elephant
business pleasure Raisman is a Silicon
Valley paying a function Jota so no
thousand you take us here from took a
potato potato only hold your major
purposes playing with children you ain't
your lunatic in New Hampshire
she internet a business plan Yaman is a
chicken thoughts is a hominid that she
can do G they could positively fascist a
messaging Yoshi efficiency initial I can
detail the plan its mckernon Nativity
what siddhappa stuff well so I am be a
Stanford MBA cashier Tomoko Nando
why you ma Pocoyo poplar young shin
dong-hee so let's ask why you debar so
you know will hold you the plenty of
pressure
what measures in just a couple mmm a
decision you more PMOI this film has to
three hot a plan doesn't its appeal to
genesis you the function rule number six
don't worry about the competition when
you do business
don't worry about competition there's no
where it is well there's no competition
you have to
not a stop to oblige they ship the world
is getting so small if you cannot stop
it improve it
about the competition today it's like a
10,000 meters of running for the first
200 meters don't think that guy is the
competitor keep on running 3,000 meters
later you were no force competitor rule
number seven focus on your customers and
your team spending time all your
customers spend time or your people on
your own team don't spend time I
investors don't spend time on your
competitors where you look at the people
you want to serve wait look at the
people you work together if they're
happy you will win that's the very
simple rule number eight hire your
weaknesses so what symbolism well
touching Hamid's have put him back
coding system Oh question what a genie
awaits take a holistic Putin chairman
party search its amicus Vlad Pocoyo
where Pato chi-su Putin impotent oMG so
Sarah Lehman College is near converts
hodja hodja to avoid some Sicilian at
cinematography mega top they were woman
my focaccia yea so la da da da da da da
consensus page ago CEO Bachchan potency
so Rossini NSE a sociopath Oh chi-su
logo CEO haunches Canyon - Danny P
anyway acaba they were they were cutting
a tomato can Tameka even oppose against
Ibaka so in a Warren King at the cans at
hammer
Naji Nahas what they were because they
contain sufficient anyway Mary Carter my
super shape mayor you're coding sewage
and her purse attaching changing each
analyst engine sound Mandarin what you
this talent but take a soil water and
here comes a peon tenacious forces show
Mike respect to the soy contains the
cinnamon cap a little sushi water so
vision vision poopy intentions
aventure imagine the pizza needs of our
business yes so you know consensus Alma
comes to email is the UI soil really any
purpose amici so that we are in sasame
check mommy but no cheese was Avenue G
Sunnah Johnny Otis Armando consider
consensus hola dahveed she doesn't watch
yet yeah you're a mango a teacher ha my
epitome cheese soup once also found in
seconds and it softens about Kenya
warehouse craving down a hub when your
tunes on day huh
rule number nine be strategic my my view
is that if when you have twenty to
thirty years old you should have follow
a good boss joining a good company to
learn how to do things properly when
you're thirty to forty years old if you
want to do something yourself just do it
you're sticking afford to lose to fail
but when you're forty to fifty years old
my suggestion is that you should do
things that you are good at right and
not do things that oh that's very
interesting I want to try something new
it's be dangerous more when you're fifty
to sixty years old
spending time training and developing
young people the next generation when
you see over sixty years old
better stay with your grandchildren but
this is normally general like that not
everybody like but most of the people
who looked at so thirty years old we
people next to thirty years are they
like Easter period we're a lot of
challenges a lot of things that's
happening and with our knowledge with
our
physical power it's time you need to
change you have to think we all if you
want to be successful tomorrow it's
impossible if you want to be successful
a year later it's impossible
but if you want to win ten years later
you have chance that is what I think
and you'll number 10 the last one we for
a very special bonus clip is served the
planet I want to do education because I
was a trained to be a teacher I feel
guilty for only taught school for six
years I feel good about that
so that's why I'm talking everywhere I
think of myself CEOs chief Education
Officer try my best to communicate so in
a sec I think China education system
people say the problem China
education is teaching his knowledge is
so good it's uncle the childhood eat
teaching we're the best
one of the best in the world go to any
universities Chinese students taking
exams or the best in the Stanford I
think pretty good they're very good but
II the count of it that they eat the
culture teamwork these are terrible so
we got to put more efforts on that this
is something I want to help
the second environment I worry about the
air pollution the water all these things
and and so that's why I joined the
Nature Conservancy and the other thing
that the infrastructure of the
philosophy you know Bill Gates tried to
convince me and work with Warren Buffett
years ago came to China which had donate
every money and I asked them well how
old are you
Wallen is 80 I said when I'm 80 I would
donate my money
I'm only 40 what is my what is my friend
the pea China go to Beijing Shanghai
they're rich police but there are only
small part of China go to the east us
where's the part of China so many
Portero policies as a business guy
created jobs give the more business
making sure people have jobs making sure
people are alive good conditions this is
the key now gonna start you're born
escape from Jack Ma and how to be
responsible that I think you're gonna
enjoy but before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions let's go
from just watching the video to take in
action here we go question number one
how will you better serve the planet
number two what weakness do you have
that you need to hire for it and number
three where do you need to stop planning
the thing is that for me people like me
are people say i jack you are very rich
no but I don't have time to spend money
and I know this money's that does not
belong to me when I have a 1 minute 2
minute it's my money but we have 20
minute problem comes you think the u.s.
daughters who gets the valley or Ingrid
pawn and the stock market is gonna
problem when you're over 1 billion
dollars that is the responsibility
because the society trusted you can
manage the money better if you think
that is your money you'll get into
trouble this is what I always believed
that's them how can a person have a you
note in teal or make 2 billion dollars
no matter how hard we hop harder your
work you should not get to been out to
do get in the money people put on you is
the trust and credit you have so you
should have spent a money better than
government you should spend money better
than the other people spending money on
the right places
if you want more 10 awesome rules from
Jack check out their video right there
next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there if you want to be successful learn
from the other people's mistakes don't
learn from the successful stories don't
hate your competitors